(muffled scraping)
(Tucker laughs)
- Disgusting, no, no, no, no, no!
- I don't think I have bad breath,
but like everyone kind of
does a little bit, right?
Apparently, a significant
amount of bad breath
actually comes from bacteria
that is made on the tongue,
and not on your teeth.
When you brush your teeth,
you're only doing part of the job
which is where this guy comes in.
This is a tongue scraper,
and it is supposed to remove
the grossness from your tongue.
I recently came across it through a TikTok
and I thought to myself,
"Hm, my breath could probably be better."
I've also sent these to some co-workers
and they are going to
give you their thoughts.
Viewer discretion is definitely
advised for this one.
You're gonna have to look at this.
Ahhhhhh, a lot.
(upbeat music)
- I'm eating some Goldfish, so that
when my tongue is disgusting,
I can be like, "Oh,
it's just 'cause I ate."
As opposed to having
like a disgusting tongue.
Does that make sense?
- I'm so excited because I
personally love gross things.
I love to go on YouTube and watch people
pop other people's pimples
and I also love to see
when ear wax comes out of someone's ear.
- I think my dental hygiene is like good.
I brush my teeth, I floss every day.
I mean what more could you ask?
I suppose you could use a tongue scraper,
that's more you could ask.
- Tongue scrapers.
(metal clinking)
Never really been on the agenda.
It looks like an evil surgical
instrument from the past.
- So let's see what's up with my tongue.
Ahh.
(Tucker scoffs)
Okay, well the tongue is disgusting.
- So we're gonna get
up close and personal.
(whimsical music)
- Oh yeah.
That's my tongue.
- If you're worried about gagging,
start at the middle of your tongue.
I'm not worried.
(Dakota gags)
- Made me gag a bit.
(whimsical music)
- Ew.
- Ooh, that's nasty.
That just came off of my tongue.
(whimsical music)
(Tucker moans)
- Absolutely not.
You straight up have like
liquid coming out, hold on.
(upbeat whimsical music)
Ahhh.
Absolutely not.
Are you kidding me right now?
Are you kidding me?
(upbeat whimsical music)
- It just leaves my tongue dry.
- I'm getting some stuff off here.
(Sheryl gags)
- I went too far in.
(whimsical music)
- Ugh!
If Goldfish sees that this
video got out, (scoffs)
it'd be game over for them,
because this is disgusting,
and I am blaming this on Goldfish.
(upbeat whimsical music)
(Tucker aggressively moans)
Aggressive tongue scraping.
Okay, so this is for
sure, like that worked.
That is straight up gunk.
So now let's see what happen.
(upbeat music)
- Overall, I feel like my breath
is a little bit more fresh.
Of course, I still need to
floss and brush my teeth.
- My mouth does feel a little bit cleaner
now that it doesn't have
that gross gunk in there.
I feel like I can just
keep doing this for hours
and more stuff would come out.
It's like when you're popping a pimple
and you're like, "How is
there more stuff in there?"
Like legally, how is
more stuff coming out?
- Overall, I'll say this
thing worked pretty well.
My mouth definitely feels cleaner,
and the saliva that came off of my tongue
was not the clearest
saliva that I think of.
There was definitely some
plaque buildup on there.
- I will definitely be incorporating this
into my personal care routine.
- Will I continue doing it?
You know what, I have the product now,
I'm gonna give it a go!
I will continue doing it.
(upbeat music)